das ist wirklich der hammer die mammuts
sind erst vor 4000 jahren ausgestorben
das sagt eine neue studie
erdgeschichtlich quasi vor ein paar
sekunden die pyramiden von gizeh die
standen schon die menschen hätten ihn
damals fast den garaus gemacht doch eine
kolonie der haarigen elefanten überlebte
auf der wrangel insel im nordosten
sibiriens doch dann begann ein
mysteriöses massensterben warum kriegs
um science-fiction ihr gibt es täglich
spannende science videos abonniert den
kanal und aktiviert die glocke nur dann
verpasst er nicht los geht
herzlich willkommen
die mammuts sind typische vertreter der
eiszeitlichen tierwelt sie waren
gigantisch groß und sehr haarig außerdem
ernährten sie sich ausschließlich von
pflanzen wie sträuchern und gras die
maus neben den weiten teilen europas
asiens afrikas und nordamerika fachleute
gingen lange davon aus dass die mammuts
spätestens vor rund 10.000 jahren
ausgestorben waren nicht nur die
erderwärmung nach der letzten kaltzeit
war schuld daran sondern auch die jagd
durch die menschen ganz geklärt ist das
aussterben der mammuts aber noch nicht
klar ist nur dass einige der haarigen
elefanten auf zwei inseln längere zeit
überleben konnten als die restlichen
vertreter der mammuts gattung zum einen
auf der st paul insel in währing mehr
hier könnten wohl einige wollhaarmammuts
bis vor 5.600 jahren gelebt haben und
auch die wrangel insel die heute zu
russland gehört und im nordosten
sibiriens liegt hat eine mammut kolonie
wohl deutlich länger beherbergt als man
bislang vermutet hatte
der meeresspiegel stieg nach der
beendigung der letzten kaltzeit vor etwa
15.000 jahren und schottete die insel
vom festland ab ein perfektes
rückzugsgebiet für die mammuts die dort
bis vor etwa 4000 jahren lebten
das muss man sich mal vorstellen in
dieser zeit begann in mesopotamien die
entwicklung einer modernen zivilisation
und in ägypten stand bereits längere
zeit die cheopspyramide doch dann begann
auch auf der wange insel ein mysteriöses
massensterben und die tiere verschwanden
quasi von jetzt auf gleich ein großes
rätsel für die fachwelt doch expertinnen
und experten aus kindern konnten jetzt
licht in die sache bringen
dafür untersuchten sie mammut knochen
und zähne die sie mit den überresten von
tieren aus anderen gebieten verglichen
im fokus der analyse die kohlenstoff und
stickstoff isotope aus dem knochen
kollagen der wrangel insel nahm
diese untersuchung offenbart dass es
wohl nicht an nahrung für die tiere
mangelte oder aber das futter in seiner
qualität abgenommen hatte stattdessen
waren die umweltbedingungen für die
mammuts wohl bis zu ihrem ende hin
relativ stabil
dazu schreibt das autorenteam in der
neuen studie die werte sprechen nicht
für einen allmählichen rückgang der
futterqualität oder qualität der boden
der insel hat nach ansicht des
forschungsteams genügend gräser als
nahrung hergegeben womöglich haben aber
genetische faktoren zum aussterben der
letzten mammuts population auf der
einsamen insel geführt darauf hatten
auch schon frühere studien hingedeutet
demnach haben sich im erbgut der mammuts
population auf der wange linsel
möglicherweise eine mutation nach der
nächsten angesammelt dennoch sind die
experten und expertinnen der ansicht
dass das wohl nicht die einzige ursache
für ihr relativ plötzliches aussterben
gewesen sein dürfte wahrscheinlich kam
eine wasserknappheit dazu die es den
tieren ihr leben schwer machte die
zunehmende trockenheit könnte dazu
geführt haben dass die insel den tieren
nicht mehr genug trinkwasser bieten
konnte doch die meisten hinweise
sprechen tatsächlich für ein extrem
wetter ereignis das den tieren dann
letztendlich zum verhängnis wurde dazu
der forscher herr w bush arends es
scheint durchaus denkbar dass eine von
genetischem verfall und trinkwasser
problem bereits geschwächte population
so etwas wie einem einzelnen
extremwetterereignisse lag
beispielsweise könnte es gefrierender
regen gewesen sein der das gras
ungenießbar gemacht hatte und
letztendlich dazu führte dass die tiere
verhungerten
dieses ergebnis kann lautet der
fachleute auch als warnung für die
heutige situation dienen denn auch in
dieser zeit gibt es viele taten die
isoliert leben diese sind laut der
expertin experten also besonders
gefährdet beispielsweise durch extreme
umwelteinflüsse eindeutige belege dafür
dass die menschen die letzte mammut
population auf der wange linsel
ausgerottet haben konnte das finnische
forschungsteam bislang nicht finden
riesenkalmar und mensch die begegnungen
anklicken anschauen und unbedingt
neugier zone abonnieren einer der sich
am schnellsten entwickelnden kanäle
unserem science netzwerk essent 1054
also bis dann bleibt dran